- As we predicted, Rudy
Giuliani is no longer licensed
to practice in the District of Columbia,
but don't celebrate
yet because number one,
not only is this
temporary, but number two,
this is really an administrative thing
that he had an obligation
once his law license was
suspended in New York
to notify the bar of the
District of Columbia,
which as far as I can tell
are the only two jurisdictions
where Rudy Giuliani was
licensed to practice law
in the United States.
And any bar association upon learning
that you've been suspended
in one jurisdiction
will also suspend your law
license in that jurisdiction
pending the outcome of that investigation.
And similarly, I would expect
that if the New York courts
permanently revoke Rudy
Giuliani's law license,
then he would be permanently
revoked in DC as well.
So either way, we are
not going to be seeing
Rudy Giuliani in court any time soon.